It's not hard to understand why a young boy like Benjamin Grosvenor...
...might want to be a concert pianist.
Who wouldn't?
When a young pianist, like Benjamin Grosvenor for instance,...
...here he is, he's at the beginning of this,...
...it's a hugely competitive area.
What is it that's going to make a concert pianist for today to stand out,...
...particularly in this competitive environment?
Oh, it's very difficult because there are thousands of people...
...wanting to be a concert pianist.
Obviously, natural virtuosity, the ability to learn...
...and to conquer the instrument.
All the obvious things: depth of interpretation, understanding,...
...the ability to listen to oneself, to hear the piano while playing it...
...and also charisma for the audience, having that quality...
...that forces the listener to empathize with you while you're playing...
...and to really force the public to listen.